giant apple this week became the first
ever u.s company to be worth two
trillion dollars
apple's valuation puts it on a par with
major economies
it's now surpassed the gdp of the likes
of brazil
canada russia and south korea its market
capitalizations doubled over just the
past two years most of that growth
coming since the start of the pandemic
experts now estimate if apple were in
economy it would be classified the
ninth richest in the world my colleague
eunin o'neil asked economist
edward hall and jeffrey tucker for their
thoughts on apple's two trillion dollar
valuation
does it seem as if something's not quite
right when millions are losing their
their jobs are close to it and a tiny
number getting insanely rich
that is exactly right and i have to
correct language you say
because of the pandemic it's because of
the lock downs
and all across the world and especially
in the us governments have
been bankrupting small and medium-sized
businesses
and and forced closures and stay home
orders and closing schools closing
borders stopping travel
it's been an outrage and of course who
benefits it's it's the big companies
especially the tech
giants and the rich meanwhile in this
country
the the the poor and the middle class
are suffering
and medium small businesses are going
under because
of the lockdowns not because of the
pandemic obviously that there's
plenty of encouragement for companies
like apple which
have received public funding and
from their very get-go and we really
need to see
far more diversity at the grassroots of
the economy to
to channel that kind of innovation it
seems that
large companies like apple once they
reach a threshold like this they need a
lot of public scrutiny to keep up
with that kind of responsibility of
being so large
company like that needs to be under
public scrutiny
and to perform at a higher level in
providing innovation rather than to be
monopolistic in their aims last month
apple along with google facebook amazon
were questioned
in the us congress and we're told they
have quote too much power
and are a danger to the american economy
have they become too powerful
i don't want to blame apple and google
and amazon so much as i i just think
that rules should be
applied fairly and evenly to everyone so
everyone has a chance
uh to get to get big and and wealthy and
and serve
the commerce consumer through excellence
but i think that's the most important
thing i mean
that's the essence of what we mean by
free enterprise right it's supposed to
be um
equal rules for for everyone and that is
not the situation today
people making the point that apple
google facebook for instance have have
more influence than
than most governments but is there
anything wrong with that why should
governments have a monopoly on power
that's such a fascinating question as
governments become centralized in any
fashion
there's opportunities for collusion with
with businesses
that are succeeding at a certain level
that's when we start having this
stratified rule set the rule of law
starts to break down in any country
once a company can overtake and
and work with a politician is supposed
to be protecting the public then you can
get some
you know problematic behavior that's
unaccountable and then the rule of law
breaks down
you